- L'heure des vacances a sonné.
Les be
Et, pour plusieurs, la COVID,
c'est du passé.
- Dans ma tête, moi, c'est fini!
- Bien, je me lave encore pas
le désinfectant surtout.
Mais oui, pour l'instant,
c'est du passé. En espérant
que ça revienne pas.
- Pourquoi?
- C'est plus dangereux pour moi.
- Depuis le début de la pandémie
et e
les Québécois ont autant pensé
que la COVID était derrière
nous.
EVE DUBÉ, anthropologue, INSPQ
une diminution de l'adhésion.
C'est pas surprenant,
dans un contexte où les mesures
obligatoires ont été enlevées.
national de Santé publique
du Québec, le lavage desaiains
et la distanciation physique
sont en chute libre.Les 60 ans s
plus nombreux à être prudents.
Les 18-24 ans sont ceux qui
ont abandonné les mesures
en plus grand nombre.
- Au FEQ, je pense que j'ai vuut
le masque. T'sais, je pense
qu'on est rendus ailleurs.
- Je m'en vais à un spectacle,
mais
puis je vais faire attention.
EÉvidemment, les personnes
plus âgées peuvent se sentir
la COVID, donc ont tendance
généralement à continuer
de suivre ces mesures-
alors que chez les plus jeunes,
on dit : "Jamais ou parfois."
Dr DONALD VINH, mi
Université McGill
- C'est sûr que c'est une grande
inquiétude. L'
du masque n'est pas soulignée
asassez!
- Le docteur Donald Vinh
souligne que l'explosionanananan
de la Capitale-Nationale,
affecte tous les secteurs
de la société et de l'économie.
- On pense que le virus s s s sa
réalité, c'est que si on regarde
l'impact sur notre système
de santé qui est en train,
encore une fdededededededededede
qu'on est dans le trouble.
- J'ai apporté mon masque,
mais je l'ai pas mis!
- De
s'inquiètent déjà
po l l'automne.
Sans mesures supplémentaires
les éclosions risquent encore
une fois de se mtitiplier.
Ici Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc,
Radio-Canada, Québe